si la crédibilité était une maladie elle
porterait sûrement le nom de syndrome de
cymes car rappelez-vous en début de
crise le médecin qualifié cette épidémie
de couronnes un virus de simple
grippette jeune maman je suis absolument
pas inquiet bon c'est un virus de plus
c'est qu'on le dit souvent c'est une
forme de grippe mais voilà
qu'aujourd'hui michel cymès a revu son
discours et se permet de faire la leçon
aux non vaccinés il faut se regarder
dans la glace le matin en se disant oui
je peux tuer des gens en journée il va
même plus loin en pointant du doigt les
soignants qui s'il était applaudi il ya
deux ans sont désormais tenus pour
responsables de ne pas se faire vacciner
faudra demander des comptes ceux qui ont
été médecin ou infirmière et qui ont
refusé de se faire vacciner pour des
raisons qui l'auraient probablement
personnel et déclarations que certains
voient comme une sortie de route alors
michel cymes at il été trop loin après
ses propos sur les non vaccinés
alors michel cymes at il été trop loin
après ses propos sur les non-vaccinés
merci fabrice di vizio et laurent
alexandre d'être avec nous sa sortie a
fait énormément parler il est sans pitié
avec les personnes qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés on va revoir encore un sa
sortie regarde on prend ce genre de
responsabilité celle de ne pas se faire
vacciner
il faut se regarder dans la glace le
matin en se disant oui je peux tuer des
gens à journée alors et ensuite et c'est
pas fini parce qu'ils sont ensuite pris
au personnel soignant qui n'est pas
encore vaccinés selon lui devront rien
jour répondre de leurs actes
c'est parti mais je pense qu'un jour il
faudra demander des comptes ceux qui ont
été médecin ou infirmière et qui ont
refusé de se faire vacciner pour des
raisons qui l'auraient probablement
personnel je ne m'apitoie absolument pas
sur le sort de des infirmières ou des
médecins qui ont fini par quitter ce
métier parce qu'ils n'ont pas voulu sur
le vacciner c'est leur choix c'est leur
problème alors qu'ils trouvent que
michel cymès a été trop loin après ses
propos sur le nombre de signer vous
guillaume champoux est absolument
honteux déjà en disant ça me chante il s
ils insultent des millions de français
qui refusent de se vacciner et puis il
participe à cette mode de culpabiliser
les gens sert qu'au début le coc vide
c'était de la faute de ceux qui
sortaient de chez eux ensuite c'était de
la faute des jeunes ensuite c'est de la
faute de ceux qui sont pas vaccinés mais
c'est jamais de la faute de ceux qui ont
mal géré la crise où des médecins qui
ont dit des conneries sur les plateaux
télé pendant des mois comme l'i donc
franchement je trouve ça dégueulasse
alors bougez géraldine hausse et le
comprennent en fait c'est pas vraiment
contraire parce que je comprends que
c'est une formule un peu me choque un
peu trop clivante ont parfois des souris
ont eu le choc pour sensibiliser mais je
trouve que malgré tout je trouve que
quand on est soignants aujourd'hui est
que quand l'année dernière à l'hôpital
la première cause de maladie les
maladies nosocomiales maladie qu'on
attrape canton à l'hôtel c'était locaux
vides et que les gens en moore est à
dire qu on allait à l'hôpital pour
soigner quelque chose on a frappé le
coup vidéo n'en mourrez donc je
comprends que quand on les soignants
c'est un petit peu plus que les autres
mais citoyen donc en fait on est là pour
guérir et pour protéger et je comprends
quand même cette prise de parole de
michel cymes je pense qu'il ya quand
même une sorte de responsabilité quand
on les soignants et qu'on doit se faire
vacciner voilà delphine toi tais toi tu
te tais choqué par ses propos ouais
parce que c'est encore une fois des
propos finale qui divise les gens et
puis le sens de contamination faut quand
même leur prendre on a bien dit que les
gens qui sont vaccinées peuvent
commettre porter et donc le transmettre
à quelqu'un qui n'est pas vaccinée dans
ce sens là oui mais quelqu'un qui n'est
pas vacciné déjà ne peut pas puisque si
le vaccin fonctionne tellement bien on
peut pas le faire donc
je crois qu'il va siffler on regarde et
il attend la phrase pour meubler
son regard et ses mythes l'autize et je
sais pas ce qu'il veut me faire alors
oui je le fais pas dire effectivement
quand on sait pas vaccinés on prend la
responsabilité en fait on prend le
risque d'être peut-être même contaminé
par quelqu'un qui est vaccinée dans
l'autre sens nous on est tout le temps
on se fait tester tous les trois jours
je vois pas qu'est ce qui est le plus
grave en fait jamais senti sa permanence
pardon parce que tu peux payer et et est
aussi parce que l'on est fier de ça non
mais ça c'est un autre débat mais pour
s'inviter à notre débat là
et on est relativement à jour chère mais
elle n'est pas allée pas hors la loi
soit votée on est relativement à jour
soit sélectionné au final on sait même
pas si on est porteur alors là vous
mathieu d'anjou ou dit non
quand on n'a pas de connaissances avoir
du bon sens qu'est ce que vous ne
comprenez pas dans le fait que encore
hier et un article dans le parisien qui
expliquait que 85% des gens qui sont
tombés malades n'étaient pas vaccinés
77 % des lits aujourd'hui occupée c'est
par des gens qui sont non vaccinés et
qui prête donc la place de personnes qui
peuvent avoir des vraies maladies qui ne
peuvent pas être soignés qu'on peut être
des cancers à quel moment vous allez
vous allez à moins qu'ils aient un
complot gigantesque de toute la presse
mondiale à quel moment vous allez
comprendre qu' on est malade quand on
n'est pas d'actionner fabrice parce que
là ça frôle à la je sais plus quoi vous
dire ça frôle à la bêtise je ne sais pas
ce qui se passe vous êtes avocat
[Applaudissements]
c'est un cri
muet fabrice répond de lui et foncent et
le
mels a raison
c'est toujours drôle quand fabrice de
deux ans un nom à la bouche de france a
reçu photo non france perd c'est
ce qui me donnait là tout à l'heure
c'était cette phrase de lao she dans la
ushl
[Rires]
il ya la machine
sur la aussi mort pour le printemps des
révolutions du printemps et quelle est
cette phrase que je voudrais faire
mienne uniquement le silence est parfois
une forme de résistance c'est là où j ai
donc je vais juste me taire en fait ça
des propos propos de mathieu les propos
de michel cymes il mérite même pas
d'être commenté sa médaille c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné moi je veux bien il
ya deux choses chez michel cymes qui a
le personnage et il ya effectivement le
fond du propos ce sont deux choses
différentes michel cymes c'est quelqu'un
qui fait la leçon aux soignants mais qui
n'est lui qu'à lui-même démissionné de
l'assistance publique dit il parce que
eh bien ça lui prenait trop de temps
d'être à la fois médecin et personnage
médiatique donc on a quelqu'un qui a
déserté l'hôpital et qui aujourd'hui
effectivement donne des leçons à ses
confrères premier élément deuxième
élément france se souviennent michel
cymes qui est un homme plein de
certitudes mais qui en mars 2001 et
janvier les images à théo avait quand
même dit effectivement sur europe 1 que
mais ils font alors qu'on était en plein
trip non il est pas exactement dit ça il
avait dit que c'est un virus comme les
autres
c'est fini sinon oui monsieur division
était à l'époque du confinement qui l'
ai dit ça maintenant sur le fond du
propos à moi je veux bien effectivement
qu'on stigmatise qu'on culpabilise et je
veux bien concret 7 10 sociétés de
gustave thibon ça me pose aucun problème
simplement il ya une étude qui est paru
récemment là je veux dire à au journal
européen a fait des petits de myologie
casse est intéressante parce qu'elle
s'est posé la question de savoir si
finalement le taux de vaccination
avaient une incidence sur l'épidémie bah
la réponse est non voilà l'étude le met
en évidence c'est à dire qu'elle nous
dit de façon assez claire sahara que non
c'est sylvie un ennemi que le vaccin
pour les former à la honte imax à s'y
installer
elle dit qu'effectivement les pistes
plateau là ça protège en partie contre
les formes graves mais ce qu'elle dit
elle dit voilà bah c'est aussi la seule
utilisation de la vaccination comme
principale stratégie protein le coc vide
et ses conséquences néfastes réexaminer
surtout compte tenu du vaillant delta et
cetera une telle correction de cap en
particulier en ce qui concerne le récit
politique devient primordial avec les
preuves scientifiques émergentes sur
l'efficacité réelle des vaccins tout une
étude pour dire chasse alouettes ray
jamais peut-être je termine je termine
mais croyez ce que vous voulez moi je
suis pas là pour vous empêcher de vous
répondrai pas aux questions là un thème
quel parisien 85 pense ans des gens
malades ne sont pas vaccinés répondez à
sabha je répondrais prétoire le mans je
réponds que israël a démontré ce que
vous dites est pas vrai
enfin je les ai parisien des de la merde
si on compare les parisiens aux études
d'israël parce que vous m
alexandre terminer sur un propos et
l'étude vis quelque chose que je trouve
vraiment en réponse à michel cymes qui
est vraiment important elle dit ceci en
résumé même si des efforts doivent être
faits pour encourager les populations se
faire vacciner ils doivent le faire avec
humilité et respect à un les populations
stigmatisante peuvent faire plus de mal
que de bien il importe de souligner
d'autres efforts de prévention en
alcoologie comme le lavage des ronds on
a compris résultat est plaisant de se
faire vacciner avec humilité d histoire
sur ce elle préfère garder le silence
parce que ce genre de propos véhéments
très irrespectueux oui c'est vrai je
veux dire c'est profondément
irrespectueuse et vous dites et si vous
pensez effet qu'un disciple de lao she
et si vous foncez que vous allez
convaincre des gens tout à vacciner avec
de telles prouesses méprisant et barrez
vous trompez pas ce que le mépris ça
marche moi je ne joue pas qu'avec des
gens passionnants michael vous plaît ça
non c'est plus que ça j'entends faire
ses preuves parce que toujours rendre
des comptes non lâchait combo vaut mais
rendre des comptes de quoi vous vous
prenez pour qui pour me parler pas mais
vous êtes qui excusez moi mais vous vous
prenez pour qui d'abord j'ai une liberté
je l'exercent super je veux dire voilà
ça c'est le premier point est géré dans
deuxième élément qui compte très
important c'est quand même effectivement
de souligner ici qu'il n'y a pas
d'obligation maximale et que donc tout
cas pas d'obligation vaccine arrêts je
ne suis pas hors la loi en ne faisant
pas vaccinés et il vous plaira quand
même de l'entendre à un moment donné que
en venant me mépriser quand arrêter
votre mépris mais on vous dit à la télé
au relais aux gens de ne pas se faire
vacciner
non là l'idée c'est que tous les
arrêtés de tout schéma quoi diviser je
suis un mais c'est fou vous avez des
habitants est fait pour nous dans votre
apport mais pas à la télé je ne suis pas
venu à la télé pour dire aux gens qu'il
faut pas si un actionnaire il a jamais
de faire mieux à la télé pour répondre à
une question qui m'est posée sur michel
cymes à gaza temps vous êtes posé la
question de savoir si les propos de
michel cymes est vrai effectivement sont
dérangeants ben voilà compétition
dérange avec des actions pour le droit
d'avoir un avis divergent du grand
auteur et si vous avez le droit accord
laurent alexandre d'accord d'abord
d'abord je constate avec un immense
plaisir que m division qui nous avait
dit qu'il viendrait plus jamais à l'abri
et que jamais il ne prendrait le pas de
sanitaires et ce soir et et les
sanitaires pourraient troquer une sur
nous est si cher
voire je me laisserais
non je n'ai aucune envie choisit alors
je ne veux pas qu'ils ambiguïté je ne
suis venu parce que j'ai reçu comme
d'habitude les engagements que tout le
monde se soit fait tester absolument pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non ça suffit
laurent et jean paquette nominem je peux
dire est ont quand même
du mépris effectivement et jacques sylla
s'ouvrir à monopoliser david je devais
prendre ce point elle est on jouerait de
rennes problème avec tallec series moi
la question dimensions gramat et c'est
encore bien
je
constatais que m division est là
contrairement à ce qu'il avait dit nous
sommes tous heureux très heureux alors
après sur ce qu'a dit si metz il ya deux
choses il ya sur la population générale
il est hors de question de pousser les
gens d'obliger les gens à être vaccinés
en revanche pour les soignants je suis
d'accord avec cymes ma maman a été
hospitalisée elle est très âgées
récemment je n'aurais pas voulu qu'elle
soit entouré par des infirmières n'ont
vacciné je ne l'aurais pas voulu et je
le voudrais pour personne ici donc nous
devons en tant que choix niant être
vaccinés pour protéger les gens et pour
protéger les familles à faire ce qu'on
sait que le vaccin ne protège pas à 100%
de la contamination mais il diminue la
contamination sur l'efficacité du vaccin
on a la plus grande étude du monde qui
est sorti il ya trois jours chekir 22
millions de français on voit que le
vaccin diminue de 90 ans les
hospitalisations et les morses et puis
on ne sait pas ça aujourd'hui
c'est pas
ça
22 millions de patients étudiés c'est la
plus grande
avec le grand déçu alexandre
effectivement passe son temps à nous
vanter des études notamment celle sur 22
millions qui montrerait que ce vaccin
est efficace et 90%
combien donc cette étude elle comprend
plusieurs tranches d'âge dont les plus
de 75 ans d'accord d'accord tu as lu le
rapport donc elle comprend bien une
partie concernant les plus de 75 ans
on est d'accord ou pas oui mais on est
d'accord a manifestement je sais pas je
suis alexandre effectivement celui dans
un silence curieux on est d'accord ou
pas tu l'as lu
naturel à lui est une ou pas je crois
qu'il avec lao she
comes la direction ne pas me répondre a
pas de débat donc j'ai passé directement
aux propos de monsieur cymes si vous
voulez je pense qu'effectivement tout ça
comme monsieur alexandre finalement
michel cymes lille un point commun n'est
pas médecin et des télé-évangélistes on
peut dire certains médecins un plateau
sont devenus des télé-évangélistes qui
globalement viennent c'est ce que fait
monsieur alexandre sur ce plateau vous
explique à travers d'une étude non revue
par les pairs qui effectivement contient
des biais colossaux qu'un étudiant de
deuxième année pourrait voir mais non
puisque l'étude elle est sortie et bien
à quelques jours du vote par le sénat de
l'obligation vaccinale et que le
gouvernement la promeut et baal et bien
c'est bien lui c'est le bien si mais
c'est le bien et nous on est le mal ok
mais ça ça peut être un télévangéliste
ça peut être pas être un médecin et moi
vous comprenez que je veux bien débattre
de tout mais certainement pas de
religion que chacun a la sienne en la
matière et que j'envie débat pas de
religion et qu'en l'espèce effectivement
nous en sommes arrivés au fait religieux
que comme il sait le visuel ci mais je
termine là dessus est capable d'insulter
comme il le fait des gens alors qu'il
fait vautré comme un âne au mois de mars
en venant effectivement parler de ce
virus qui
dérangeait pas avec raul s'est pas de
répit l'a pas fait autant d'erreurs s'il
vous plaît
vous en avez ce que lui merci 500
millionième
ces bons candidats chez moi j radio
n'est pas tant on attend d'en voir des
invités à
l'euro à
tous cyril je vais le leur je pense
vraiment que cette étude elle est très
encourageante d'accord tu me tues moi je
fais partie des gens nous avions mangé
liste
c'est open the brain valérie
s'il a lu par action vous l'avez lu oui
évidemment il a lu un corps doit y aller
alors je trouve que ces résultats sont
très encourageants
moi personnellement j'ai même fait la
troisième injection puisque j'ai eu j'ai
eu mes deux premières injections il y a
dix mois en janvier 2022 ya donc cette
semaine j'ai eu mon injection de rappel
je suis très confiant dans le vaccin je
considère que pour les non soignants ce
qu'a dit si metz est un petit peu
excessif en revanche pour les soignants
je considère que nous avons une
responsabilité et il est déraisonnable
de ne pas être vaccinés canton d eau au
contact de malades fragiles des
cancéreux des gens qui ont des tas de
pathologies il est irresponsable de
risquer de contaminer les gens qui qui
qui vous confient leur vie quand on est
soignants donc il a raison de dire hey
regardez les soignants doivent être
vaccinés michel cymes as at il été trop
loin après ces propos sont un excellent
et 71% je suis d'accord avec vous et non
pour nom à 28%